[Music]
greetings [ __ ] uncle Joey here
Monday November 22nd my brother Mike
Ronnie's birthday and it's your birthday
too
you ever think about in the shower while
you're watching your monkey that today
could be your last [ __ ] day on earth
did you everything about that you get
shot today you die of a heart attack
like me you're fat [ __ ] you get hit by a
car and you're sitting there thinking
about [ __ ] stupidity and [ __ ] when
you wake up in the morning you gotta
make believe it's your last [ __ ] day
on this planet and you're gonna sling
dick - your dick falls or if I told you
this morning you're gonna die at
midnight tonight what would you do
that's how you gotta live every day who
gives a [ __ ] about Clinton in this intro
there's a [ __ ] would you give a [ __ ] if
it was your last day I don't know you
beat and [ __ ] grabbing Teddy smoking
reefer that's how you gotta live every
day if not shoot yourself right now
and discussed when it comes like a
Monday Monday is the attitude when it
kicks it if today was your last [ __ ]
day would you act like a jerk-off let's
go see Harry Potter get the [ __ ] out of
you
you go [ __ ] stab [ __ ] spend
money I say you gotta live every [ __ ]
day just in case you get hit by a
[ __ ] car
you never know we're smoking reefer the
podcast is ready for you and you're
three days away from tryptophan fall
asleep on the couch with your mouth open
and listen to [ __ ] up stories from
your relatives but Uncle Joe is here to
save the [ __ ] day I'll be with you
all day smoking weed for eating turkey
to hoping but let's worry about today
tremendous a chip from parami we should
have make you go bananas last night I
came home I had a [ __ ] salary at
doing the more I was [ __ ] up and
that's what you want this week could be
[ __ ] up I feel great telling everybody
if I got jujitsu I got a meeting for
Animal Planet I'm trying to put together
a cat show and that's it Gucci comes out
we're always swinging at the [ __ ]
fences if you're not swinging today
why even watching this you're wasting
your [ __ ] time it's Monday you don't
need anything in your mind to accept
what's gonna make you drunk and happy
now how you're gonna get ahead
everything else is background music look
Nico's birthday unfried who does the
[ __ ] about Nico in his birthday I give a
[ __ ] about Joe you know I don't give a
[ __ ] about birthdays understand well
listen enough is enough I smoked a
little [ __ ] reefer and get Monday
started correctamundo correct
oh if it's 9:00 a.m. and you and I go
shoot yourself at the [ __ ] neck
understand I'm getting stoned to the
gills this morning I [ __ ] to do and
people to see I'm doing the national
anthem so long I'm gonna stand up and I
sister suck my dick and if you don't
like what I'm saying so can you you
gotta be [ __ ] swinging for the fences
seven days a week 24 hours of [ __ ]
David and my [ __ ] dreams I'm jumping
over fences and [ __ ]
so that's what Monday to me oh you blow
up a [ __ ] bad air but that [ __ ]
dirty smoke then you feel it going into
your mind what you gather what you see
things that don't come easily
are you [ __ ] nuts
but 2017 is right around the door
[ __ ] so you know it's
Thanksgiving and there you go next thing
you know you're given our presents
you [ __ ] tap you don't know what to
do you don't need the aggravation we got
a job somebody's got a number for you
today somewhere you have an idea [ __ ]
and put it to work for up these
[ __ ] trying to tell you you
can't it's what you can do pops up you
can't smoke you can't expand your mind
and you can't get out there
wretched ghost do your push-ups take
care your phone back doornail and
everything falls into place I gotta go
on a mission from Satan you know I love
you [ __ ] don't forget Wednesday
night
eight o'clock Irvine improv Lisa and
Steve surround myself in a bag of stars
that's all you need to [ __ ] know be
there or be square you want to start the
Thanksgiving holiday off right hey the
clock at 10 you're gonna see your
college buddies and jump up and down huh
huh it's so great to see you all that
[ __ ] or when you're with uncle Joey
or with uncle Joey [ __ ] the
podcast is ready for you another one
tomorrow
and that's all I need to tell you you
need to go out there and make the best
day you can today that's it that's what
can [ __ ] everybody I'll [ __ ] these
Millennials and stuff these other people
with their [ __ ]
and I said nice that like I should be
doing people to see go get me [ __ ]
together
stab the [ __ ] it's Monday [ __ ]
you gotta get what's coming to you
alright what's coming to you I don't
know that's up to you the rest is
background [ __ ] music
stay black uncle Joey loves you and
don't take [ __ ] from nobody telling